es ist ein richtig verregneter sommer
und das bedeutet unsere tomatenpflanzen
haben dieses jahr ein ganz großes
problem
das ist die wahrscheinlich fieseste
thoma in krankheit überhaupt die kraut-
und braunfäule und deswegen zeige ich
euch in diesem video sowohl was ihr tun
könnt damit eure pflanzen gar nicht erst
krank werden aber auch ein einfaches
hausmittel dass ihr selber anmischen
könnt mit dem ihr eure pflanzen
hoffentlich retten könnt wenn sie schon
gefallen sind
ich hatte selber vor ungefähr fünf oder
sechs jahren als es schon mal so einen
verregneten sommer gab so gut wie gar
keine eigene tomatenernte weil im juli
schon alle pflanzen von der kraut- und
braunfäule gefallen sind und das war mir
eine absolute leere seitdem setzte ich
jeden der tipps die ihr euch in diesem
video hier verrate sehr pedantisch an
meinen tomaten um weil ich das nicht
noch mal erleben möchte und das
funktioniert richtig gut deswegen heute
mal besonders gut aufpassen das ist ein
wichtiges video heute und da es erst
erstes mal ganz wichtig dass die
pflanzen schön luftig stehen das heißt
dass man einen groß genug um
pflanzabstand einhält und dass man die
pflanzen auch regelmäßig entblättert und
ausgereizt damit er viel luft zwischen
den pflanzen zirkulieren kann und die
luft nicht so zwischen den pflanzen
steht
er hatte im unteren bereich der pflanze
entferne ich immer alle blätter gerade
wenn sie den boden berühren aber auch
ein bisschen drüber weil von da der
erreger am leichtesten an die pflanze
rankommt das heißt im unteren sagen wir
mal viertel oder fünftel der pflanze
wirklich sehr radikal alle blätter
entfernen warum ist das so wichtig weil
tomatenpflanzen überhaupt nicht gerne
nach sind weil sie dann eben ganz
schnell die kraut- und braunfäule
bekommen können das ist auch der grund
warum es so wichtig ist dass man wenn
man tomatenpflanzen gießt die blätter
nicht nass macht sondern nur auf den
boden ließ das wissen wahrscheinlich die
meisten von euch und jetzt kommt eine
aussage die wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
umstritten ist aber ich sage immer leute
domat nur im freiland anzubauen komplett
ungeschützt ohne dach überm kopf erst
ein bisschen heikel in den meisten
jahren geht das sehr gut gerade wenn man
haut volle tolerante sorten anbaut oder
sehr freiland geeignete sorten wie zb
die martina oder dbv das ist übrigens
auch ein tipp also wenn ihr im freiland
man baut dann immer nur sorten die dafür
auch geeignet sind
aber man weiß nie wieder sommer wird und
dieses jahr hat man damit schon echt
probleme und vor fünf jahren hatte ich
damit auch sehr große probleme und
deswegen bin ich eher dafür dass man ein
kleines tomaten darüber sein beet baut
wenn man schon kein gewächshaus hat das
muss ja auch nicht großartig schick oder
teuer sein aber so ist man in den jahren
wo die crowd wolle eben ein
riesenproblem ist wie in diesem jahr
einfach auf der sicheren seite weil es
total schade ist und ich weiß dass es
ganz vielen von euch gerade so geht wenn
man überhaupt keine eigenen tomatenernte
dich mein tomaten sind das beste gemüse
dass man im garten anbauen kann und dann
soll das auch bitte jedes jahr klappen
oder eine andere pflanze die
wahrscheinlich jeder von euch an bord
die auch von dem kraut und braunfäule
erreger befallen wird ist die kartoffel
und da müssen wir besonders gut
aufpassen weil sich die tomatenpflanzen
im sommer meistens anstecken weil der
erreger von den kartoffeln kommt und das
war auch in diesem jahr von dem ich euch
erzählt habe mein großes problem ich
habe die tomaten und die kartoffeln viel
zu dicht nebeneinander gepflanzt und
dann sind die kartoffeln krank geworden
und die tomaten kurz danach auch das war
super super ärgerlich und deswegen mein
tipp an euch tomaten und kartoffeln
immer so weit wie möglich auseinander
anbauen und wenn ihr in den kartoffeln
gearbeitet habt dann niemals danach
direkt zu euren tomaten gehen sondern
zumindest erstmal hände waschen wenn
nicht sogar umziehen um zu verhindern
dass die kartoffel in die tomaten an
strecken eine möglichkeit mit der man
seine pflanzen stärken kann ist die
ackerschachtelhalm jahre
dafür hört man sich einfach
ackerschachtelhalm der wächst oft am
wegrand bistümer schauen wo er welchen
findet packte ihn in einen großen eimer
an kein metall einer sonder und plastik
einmal zum beispiel verwenden
schön wasser drauf packen jeden tag
umrühren und so könnt ihr euch eure
eigene jahr herstellen
damit die pflanzen gießen das stärkt die
von innen heraus die auch er kann man
auch verdient also ist immer ganz
wichtig dass man pflanzen ja auch und
verdünnt egal welche pflanzen man
verwendet aber dann kann man die auf die
blätter drauf sprühen um gegen die
kraut- und braunfäule vorzugehen
und jetzt kommen wir zum akuthilfe teil
was man machen kann wenn die pflanzen
schon befallen sind
es ist ganz wichtig dass man sobald man
befallene blätter erkennt die entfernt
und wenn eine pflanze ganz besonders
schlimm betroffen ist und die anderen
eigentlich noch ganz gut aussehen dann
auch wenn es wehtut rettet ihr die
anderen pflanzen indem ihr die besonders
schlimm betroffenen pflanze einmal über
dem boden abschneidet dann ganz
vorsichtig entfernt sodass ihr die
anderen möglichst nicht berührt und von
den tomaten weg bringt man kann
betroffene pflanzen auch kompostieren
weil der erreger nur auf lebendigen
pflanzen überwintern kann das heißt die
dürfen auch auf den kompost wandern aber
man sollte damit eben jetzt nicht einmal
durch ganze tomaten beet gehen damit
sich der die spuren dann überall
verteilen dass wir nicht gut es dauert
aber immer seine zeit bis so eine jahre
dann fertig ist und wenn es richtig
schnell gehen soll habe ich noch einen
anderen trick für euch und zwar kocht
ihr euch da erstmal eine salbeitee weil
salbei auch eine anti pilz wirkung hat
und zwar ist die nicht zu unterschätzen
davon braucht ihr einen liter den
erstmal abkühlen lassen und dann rührt
ihr da zwei esslöffel backpulver rainha
backpulver wirkt auch sehr gut gegen die
kraut- und braunfäule weil das den pilz
austrocknet und das ganze dann einmal in
eine sprühflasche füllen und die
pflanzen von oben bis unten damit
einsprühen das ist ein super einfaches
hausmittel das wahrscheinlich jeder von
euch zu hause da hat das extrem gut
gegen die kraut- und braunfäule hilft
wir haben ja jetzt ganz viel über das
ausreizen und das entblättern gesprochen
weil das eben sehr wichtige maßnahmen
sind damit die tomatenpflanzen gesund
bleiben und darüber habe ich schon mal
ein eigenes video gemacht wo ich euch
genau zeige welche blättermann entfernt
weil man aussetzen sollte wie viele
blätter man an einem tag entfernt und so
weiter und dass verleger ich euch gerne
da drüben ansonsten geht raus macht die
welt ein bisschen grüner und wir sehen
uns nächsten samstag wieder um 10 für
ein neues video